good morning good morning and welcome to
the American Enterprise Institute my
name is Alex Brill and I'm a resident
fellow here at AEI our event today is
titled assessing the impact of tax
reform and it's my pleasure to have the
opportunity to introduce our keynote
speaker senator Orrin Hatch senator
hatch is well-known to this audience as
the chairman of the Senate Finance
Committee the senior senator from Utah
and president pro-tem of the United
States Senate you may also know him from
his appearances on the television show
Parks and Rec his well-regarded sense of
humor his effective Twitter speed and of
course his musical talents senator hatch
is also of course an accomplished
legislator his most recent
accomplishment is the subject of today's
conference
now I must confess that on at least one
occasion I have praised the Speaker of
the House of Representatives and the
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee for their leadership over the
last two years on the efforts of tax
reform and I may have said on occasion
over that period of time that the Senate
should be more publicly engaged in the
debate and efforts to reform our tax
code well I suggest you read the final
tack tax text of the tax cut and Jobs
Act bill it has the Senate Finance
Committee's handprints all over it what
the house started the Senate Finance
Committee finished that deal is now law
and the changes that have occurred
particularly with respect to business
income are profound to share his views
on the subject please join me in
welcoming senator Orrin Hatch
well this is a privilege for me to be
here this is such a great organization
and it's one that I have paid a lot of
attention to over the years and a fought
alongside you know great many battles
that are very important to this country
so I'm grateful to be with you this
morning I want to thank you very much
for the kind introduction hopefully I
won't say anything to make you regret it
then again I am grateful for the
opportunity to be here today and to
participate in this event the folks here
at AEI do some great work we depend on
them quite a bit up there on Capitol
Hill to provide information backgrounds
and of course context in a number of key
issues I have relied on an AI for many
years and a wide variety of issues they
also worked to educate the public on the
right policies that will help our
economy and our people to prosper today
we're here to talk about some important
issues particularly the impact of the
new tax law and what all of it means for
our country going forward it took quite
a bit of work to finally get our tax
reform legislation over the finish line
as you probably noticed and as we've
seen in recent weeks the country is
already starting to benefit from it it's
a good thing the economy is doing so
well particularly for me as you have
heard I'm going to be out of work here
at the end of this year I don't want to
make this event awkward front even but
if any of you know anyone who might be
hiring people please put in a good word
for me I've got a fair amount of
experience but even if it's not
technically enough for a particular job
I'm a really quick learner I'll make
sure you all get copy of my resume now
that was joking
I think I'm cut it to fine but seriously
I think it's fair to say that the new
tax law is paying off much earlier and
most of the thought most of us thought
it would which is a good thing I'd like
to talk for a moment about some of the
specific things we were able to do on
tax reform because much of it bears
repeating from the outset of last year's
efforts between both chambers of
Congress and the administration one of
our chief goals was to provide
significant tax relief for the middle
class and by enacting reforms to both
the individual and business tax systems
I think almost anybody would conclude we
were successful in that effort on the
individual side we were able to lower
rates across the board with tax payers
in the middle class getting the largest
proportional benefit of the tax cuts
opponents of tax reform conveniently
overlooked the fact that fact by
focusing only on the total benefits
enjoyed by specific tax cohorts but if
you look at the system-wide
distributional effects of the new new
law you'll see some pretty significant
benefits for middle-income families the
analysis by the Joint Committee on
taxation concluded that as a percentage
of taxpayer income the largest tax cuts
go to those in the middle and lower
income brackets post reform knows that
the higher end of the income spectrum
will actually see their overall share of
the tax burden go up slightly in
addition to lowering rates we
significantly increase the standard
deduction and expanded the child tax
credit which provided additional
targeted relief to the middle class also
for tens of millions of American
families filling out tax returns will be
a much simpler manner thanks to the new
tax law with a dramatic increase in the
standard deduction
we ensured that the vast majority of US
taxpayers more than nine out of ten will
be able to file a simple return without
going through the previous maze of
deductions and credits now that's
something that has also been overlooked
but if people continue to evaluate the
impact of tax reform I think they'll see
some significant savings in both time
and money on the part of middle-class
taxpayers because of this simplification
now let's move to the business side
America has always had an innate
entrepreneurial spirit encoded in its
DNA and for most of our nation's history
our government has tried to foster that
spirit encouraging our people to think
and dream big and then put in the work
to make those big thoughts and dreams a
reality but in recent decades our
governments seem to have a different
focus for too long
American job creators both large and
small were forced to operate under the
weight of a burdensome and arcane tax
code in working on tax reform fixing
that problem was another one of our
chief goals and on that count I believe
we were successful for most among the
many business tax reforms we enacted is
the reduction of the corporate tax rate
from 35% which was the highest in the
industrialized world down to 21% which
puts us roughly on a par with most of
our international trading partners prior
to the passage of our tax bill members
from both parties worked for years to
accomplish this important goal in fact
presidents Obama and Clinton Senate
Minority Leader Schumer's Finance
Committee ranking member widened as well
as former finance chairman Baucus all
supported lowering the corporate tax
rate I just mentioned these names and
there are many others to illustrate that
the idea to reduce our corporate tax
rate wasn't just something Republicans
dreamed up it was
the major focus of tax reform for people
on both sides in fact prior to last year
there were very few people outside a
Bernie Sanders rally who would honestly
argue that our corporate tax rate should
not condemn very very few and for good
reason
you have to truth is that lowering the
corporate rate was always about helping
the middle class that was true when it
was a bipartisan goal and it was true at
the end of last year when Republicans
were finally able to make good on years
of promises to make that idea a reality
allowed me to demonstrate why that is
the case
according to JCT workers bear 25% of the
corporate tax burden someplace that
number much higher moreover in just the
last 20 years or so we've seen a massive
expansion of pension and retirement
assets most of which are invested in
corporate stocks perhaps surprisingly
nearly four out of every $10 investment
in stock ownership is currently held in
retirement plan accounts that is the
largest under category of overall stock
ownership in the United States and while
corporate profits have climbed steadily
over the last two decades the retirement
plans of middle-class America have
expanded as well in fact the success of
our nation's retirement system has been
the largest accumulator of middle-class
wealth in history we're talking about
trillions of dollars in pension assets
owed by owned by households and
nonprofit organizations and the total
amount has gone up by almost two hundred
percent in the last 20 years that is a
direct connection between the success of
American corporations and the growth of
chickens retirement assets so when you
hear some of my colleagues argue that
the gains for middle-class workers are
mere quote crumbs unquote and the real
money is going to stock buybacks
remember that as companies increase the
value of their stock holdings the
largest group of beneficiaries and those
people with pensions are those people
with pensions IRAs and 401ks and the
benefits of the lower corporate rate
don't end there almost every day we hear
news stories about how companies are
responding to the lower rates thanks to
the new tax law companies can
manufacture store transfer build
research innovate create paint draw
exercise plant till mow lathe carve and
keep the lights on for less than they
paid before this increased activity
means more jobs for workers and
increased benefits for current employees
this is not theoretical it's happening
before our very eyes as more and more
companies announce wage hikes bonuses
and expanded benefits for workers and
increased investment in the American
economy we've seen utility companies and
often they were lowering rates on energy
bills for customers across the board
we've seen companies like Cigna
corporation which has raised its base
wage to $16 an hour and improved its
employer 401k matches u-haul recently
announced that all of its full-time
employees would be getting twelve
hundred dollars in bonuses with
part-time employees netting five hundred
dollars all told more than 28,000 u-haul
employees will be receiving bonuses
providing them with around twenty three
million dollars in benefits Tyson Foods
announced a few weeks back that 100,000
full and part-time employees would be
getting bonuses of $1,000 and $500 Aflac
is making a one-time contribution of
$500 to every employees 401k plus they
are doubling their current match from
50% to 100% on the first 4% of
compensation and one of my personal
favorites for creativity hostess brands
will be giving their employees free
snacks for a year plus 750 dollars in
cash bonuses and another 500 of our some
401k contributions butter where are
those snacks for us poor members of
Congress and I think they should get
with it all told the number of competent
I'm only kidding of course that would
get me in real trouble
I'll told the number of companies that
have made these types of announcements
numbers and the hundreds the number of
workers who are receiving these benefits
is in the millions for a middle-class
family $1,000 is three or four car
payments a couple couple months worth of
groceries or rent or a mortgage payment
and as the economy continues to expand
American workers will continue to
benefit as will the companies that
employ them during the tax reform debate
one of my colleagues on the other side
came to the floor several times and
repeated the same slogan quote the proof
is in the paycheck unquote she was right
for millions of workers the proof is
already there for millions more that
proof will show up this week as the new
withholding amounts start to take effect
and the vast majority of Americans see
an increase in their take-home pay this
is
this is really interesting stuff to me
that may not be to you but if it isn't
you'd better get with another
organization of course the success of
the corporate tax reform goes beyond
benefits for new employees we're also
seeing Americans American multinational
companies opting to return foreign
earnings for reinvestment in the United
States let me just give you a short list
of companies that are reinvesting in the
American economy the Kraft Heinz Company
800 million dollars 80 1 billion dollars
FedEx 1.5 billion dollars Apple 30
billion dollars the ladies and gentlemen
are not even through the first quarter
of 2018 yet we're already seeing tens of
billions of announced reinvestment in
the American economy which will mean
more work for suppliers builders
contractors researchers technicians
manufacturers and many others who want
to do business here in the United States
and the funny thing is while some of us
may be a little surprised that this
happening so quickly these benefits of
tax reform or what we predicted when we
drafted the bill and our predictions
were pretty much ignored by the other
side but when we drafted the bill and
moved it through Congress we predicted
this with that last of less companies
the ones bringing earnings back to the
US there's more going on in just a lower
corporate tax rate the reforms to our
international system of had something to
do with that as well with a new tax law
we finally did away with the overly
complex and draconian worldwide tax
system and replaced it with a much more
competitive territorial system why we
tend to that years ago is beyond me
we're just stupid we did some ways that
are in accord with our international
commitments
simply stated under the new law
companies and investors will pay taxes
for the most part only on earnings
accrued here in the United States gone
are the days where complex transfer
pricing foreign tax credits and
competing patents box regimes lead
companies to move their investments and
activities offshore in search of more
favorable tax conditions much of the
pressure for companies to invert or be
taken over or to otherwise move
investments offshore has been relieved
and many of the disincentives for
companies to invest in grow businesses
here in the United States have been
eliminated as a result America is now a
place where more companies who want to
set up their headquarters create jobs
and add to our economy these moves to
bring our tax code into the 21st century
and bring us more in line with our
international competitors aren't the
only businesses reforms included in the
new tax law we also enacted some very we
also enacted some very interesting and
beneficial significant reforms for
smaller businesses for example thanks to
the work of many of our members we were
able to craft a pass through a deduction
regime that provides virtual equivalents
to the corporate rate now companies can
choose whether they want to have a
partnership corporation LLC or sole
proprietorship based on the merits and
structural benefits of those
organizational types instead of thinking
purely about reducing their tax
liability we also finally did away with
the individual mandate tax that was
established under that wonderful bill
Obamacare now if you didn't catch on I
was being very sarcastic that was the
stupidest dumbass bill that I've ever
seen now some of you may have loved it
if you do you are one of the stupidest
dumb ask people I've ever met
if this was one and there are a lot of
them up there on Capitol Hill from time
to time this was one of the most
regressive taxes in the tax code with
lower-income families paying most of the
freight the individual mandate
represented one of the great ironies of
Obamacare the law force people to buy
health insurance or pay a tax while also
making health insurance less affordable
by zeroing out the individual mandate
tax the new tax law took a major step
forward in the ongoing effort to fully
repeal and replace Obamacare all tolled
the new tax reform law and both the
individual and business sides has
already started providing for greater
benefits and security for Americans
across the board it is giving relief to
low-income families it is simplifying
the lives of millions of people in the
middle class and increasing the size of
their paychecks it is resulting in wage
growth and expanded benefits for workers
in a number of different industries and
it is making the United States a better
destination for investment and job
creation these are all good things and
they are exactly what we intended when
we crafted our legislation and work to
get it to the President's desk
I've been around a long time here and I
want to thank those here today who
played a role and helped us get to this
position that we're in and of course I
want to thank all of you for being here
this morning to listen we live in the
great
country in the world bar none I've been
all over the world a number of times by
the way and frankly there's no other
country that even comes close stars well
there might be one or two this you could
say do pretty well but they're they're
really not in the league with us as dumb
as we are and a snippet of some of our
policies have been over the years but I
can tell you that no other country can
really compete with the United States if
we allow our true entrepreneurial spirit
to go forward and I intend to see that
we do that and frankly there's been a
change up during Capitol Hill and even
my Democrat friends are starting to wake
up on some of these things the problem
is is that their major supporter happens
to be the union movement in this country
now a lot of them don't even know
anything about unions they were raised
in relatives plenty weren't hetson's a
lot about unions I was raised in the
union movement I owned a union card I
was a wood wire metal Athar they are now
carpenters they merged with the
carpenters but it was a tough trade a
very skilled trade and and I'm glad I
had that experience I was born in a
family that was not rich we were poor my
dad was this was a metal ather
fortunately he's one of the best in the
city of Pittsburgh and he taught me his
trade and to this day I'm grateful to
him I'm grateful for the fact that I
knew that trade and I was really good at
it in fact I had to make a decision
whether to continue into in that trade
where I was making journeyman's money
which was good or go to Brigham Young
University well my mother wanted me to
go on to college she thought she saw
something in me that maybe others didn't
and I was thinking very seriously but
going into my trade full-time but I
received a $25.00 scholar
shipped from Brigham Young University we
were so poor and I was so impressed with
that I decide to go to Brigham Young
University and I'm glad I did ultimately
I went to the University of Pittsburgh
School of Law on a full honor
scholarship which in itself is quite an
interesting story and became a partner
in Pittsburgh the oldest law firm in
four years and I decided to want to
raise my kids in Utah so he moved out
there and I formed my own law firm out
there and we were going great guns my
junior partner who had nothing when he
came with me other than a master's in
tax from NYU which is a lot more than
nothing but he didn't have any points of
making any money he's not worth probably
50 to 100 million dollars I'm not I left
there right at the time when we were
taking off to run for the US Senate and
I'm happy that I did it was there as far
as I'm concerned the right thing for me
to do and have the kind of a wife who
put up with that it's a wonderful
wonderful woman and I have to say that
I've enjoyed being in the United States
Senate 9 I've announced my retirement at
the end of this year Mitt Romney I think
is going to try and take my place which
is something that I pushed for a went
and talked to him personally to see if
he would do this because I don't want
somebody who cannot do important things
there to just go back there and sit in
mitt has that kind of ability where he
can bring some very good financial no no
all to the United States Senate and I
think it would be a great senator or at
least for a while I want you to know
that throughout my now 42 years in the
United States Senate the longest of any
Republican has ever served and I break
anybody I'm just stating it because it's
important
a AEI has been a very very important
organization to me I read your papers I
pay attention
to many of the publications and and many
of the oral presentations I think this
is a great organization and I feel
honored that you've invited me here
today I hope this had been too boring
for you but this is this is the way it
is if I'm not boring then I'm not doing
my job well because we tax people we
tend to be really boring is all I can
say I'm grateful to you I'm grateful to
AEI I'm grateful that you're all
studying and learning and growing I'm
grateful for those of you who helped us
up there in Capitol Hill we need to help
no matter how good you are it is so
complex today especially the tax codes
that we need help from good people like
you so be encouraged just to know that
this old boy thinks the world of you and
I'm grateful to be here today
thanks so much great to see
[Applause]
he's asked me to take a couple of
questions I've got to get my tail back
to Capitol Hill yes ma'am Oh in the back
thank you for being here ml akan I'm
from The Epoch Times I would like to
know the impact of tax cuts in the
United States on other company countries
I I know some countries expressed
worries about how US is becoming more
competitive and Germany's express their
worries do you think this will create a
new round of tax competition among
countries and are you worried in the
long term or in short term this will
create impact on US economic growth if a
tax competition starts well I'm always
concerned about all these matters but I
don't think that cutting taxes makes us
uncompetitive in fact it it basically
has caused us to soar and other
countries in this in this world have
found that to be the case - and we're in
a very competitive world right now the
United States has to compete and one of
the best ways we can just to make sure
that we provide not just an
entrepreneurial spirit that we provide
opportunities and incentives for people
in the business community to be able to
move ahead and do better it also
involves a lot of really an effective
foreign policy and I have to say we
haven't always done that so it's amazing
to me how some other countries that
become much more free enterprise and
oriented than us and over individual
countries lives and and we're we have to
catch up with some of them but the
United States is the greatest country in
the world I've traveled all over the
world and every time I've gotten back I
want to get on my knees and kiss the
ground when I compare us to any other
country in the
and bragging about I'm just saying that
this is a great country we have a great
system our Constitution works and it
works because we have a great people
here and we have a complex society made
up of people from all over the world who
wanted to come here because of
opportunity for the most part and we
shouldn't knock it we should wish you
everything in our power to keep our
country moving ahead and that means
getting government getting government
into its proper role not into an overt
overly dominant role about everything
and I think we're making some headway
some people have been very critical of
Donald Trump I was the only senator in
the United States Senate who supported
Donald Trump through the election
process the only one people thought I
was crazy and all I can say I said I
just know he was the only one who might
pull us out of the mess we're in and he
still has a lot of a lot of work to do
to be able to do that but he's just
entrepreneurial enough and crazy enough
to do it I had my heist Andy and he has
the guts to go out and do it regardless
of what the media's saying about him and
what other people are saying about him
plus he's a lot of fun to be around so
you know I think we're going to see some
pretty interesting years with with him
as our president and I think he's done a
pretty good job when you consider he has
had zero Democrat support for most of
this year and some lacking Republican
support which has made it very very
difficult if anybody would have been
crushed out of the way he was treated
over this last year why did why not let
it go at that
anybody else yes sir yes ma'am I mean
then I'll come back in the last row
again okay hi my name is Nancy Kuhn and
I'm a tax attorney I used to work at the
IRS as a tax attorney
I've been dismays the last few years
watching the IRS budget be cut cut all
these people hate you because of your
but how is there any hope that the IRS
will have budget increases so that they
can have a hope of being able to
adequately interpret and enforce this
new massive tax law you raise a very
important point because we have not been
very good to the IRS and the IRS does a
pretty darn good job under the
circumstances yeah there are things you
can criticize and things you wish you
could make better but yeah that's
something I'm certainly looking at and I
want to help them done there I think
they do a very very good job much better
than people give them credit for so keep
up the good work I'll take you and then
we'll head I don't have to do it yes
ma'am Pat lacera with Amex US tax watch
to follow up in the iris question what's
the status on the num the confirmation
hearing for the IRS nominee Charles
Reddick for what now
for the IRS Commissioner nominee Charles
Frederick what's the Senate Finance
status on that I'm not quite sure right
now III do believe that we ought to put
these people through and get him to get
him to work but I have to say that this
whole year has been a almost a tragedy
because Democrats have made us have made
us have opened votes on people that win
96 to nothing it's ridiculous and you
have to go through this whole process of
overcoming a filibuster and and all
these other delays it's really
ridiculous there's no cooperation at all
and we're starting to break through that
and the perfect illustration is on
judges now normally in the past we just
put the judges through because by the
time they go through this arduous
process
we know they're pretty darn good and
we've examined them in every possible
way but it's now become standard for us
to have to take three days or more with
every nominee because the Democrats have
required it and filibuster every judge
even though they've passed 96 to zero in
the end they hate Donald Trump so badly
but that's what they're doing to him and
I think I'd like to get them over these
juvenile approaches and and and work
together now you might say well that's
nice for you so that's what is nice for
me because I have a reputation for
working across party lines and bringing
people together the heralded reputation
came with senator Kennedy who never
passed a bill before I became chairman
the Labor Committee he was effective
because he was the leading liberal
spokesperson but he didn't have much
success in passing bills because even
the Democrats especially the Southern
Democrats hated his guts
well I didn't hate his guts I thought I
saw a really fine senator with an awful
lot of ability I didn't agree with him
on very much but I he was a hard worker
he he was willing to get involved and we
gradually formed us when I became
chairman of the labor committees for him
40 years the first time he walked over
and said I'm gonna work with you I said
well I hope so because I'm gonna need
you to help and he did and when he they
became the majority I worked with him
and helped him in the process we were
known as the odd couple
because he was very liberal I was very
conservative and and I think we did some
of the best work in the Senate at the
time and I gave him a lot of credit for
having been willing to do that and it
was quite a unique experience for him a
lot of people didn't realize the Kennedy
was beating Democrat liberal
spokesperson but as far as getting bills
through even most of
Democrats would vote for him because
they were all Southern Democrats or a
lot of them were and they didn't care
for Kennedy because they were basically
conservative Southern Democrats and when
I started to work together with him they
they liked me but they were willing to
say all right if hatch says it's all
right we've got chance and then the
liberal people who didn't want to work
with me start saying well if Kennedy
says it's all right then we have a
chance and we passed an awful lot of
legislation that is today doing a good
job for this country and I mourn the
death of Ted Kennedy he was a pain in
the neck a lot of the time but he was a
good senator and I was one of those who
really cared for him and I cared for
much more than his Democratic colleagues
did but also we but we would get into
these awful fights on the floor or we'd
be gone at each other like like banshees
and and I remember all those all those
times and it was a great learning
experience for me and I think it was for
him too because he hadn't passed many
bills fact I don't know of any bills
he'd passed before I became a chairman
of the labor committee so but it set an
example for almost everybody that
liberals and conservatives can get
together and they can do good work
together if they if they just try let me
close by saying that it's a privilege
for me to be with you hope I haven't
bored you all to death but this is a
great organization I have tremendous
respect for it I read the policy papers
that come from a and I think more on
Capitol Hill should read them and
they're generally very very good so god
bless all of you and thanks for inviting
me great to be with you
[Applause]
good morning I'm Alan the art of the
American Enterprise Institute I've heard
senator Hatch's remarks we now have the
privilege of hearing further discussion
of the tax law from a very distinguished
panel
time is short I do want to try to leave
some time at the end for audience
questions so I think we'll just dive
right in will first he'll hear from Kyle
Pomerleau of the Tax Foundation thanks
to Alan thanks Alex for inviting me I
think it was a great accomplishment that
lawmakers were able to pass this tax
package overall and here I'm gonna in my
ten minutes of time strict ten minutes
I'm gonna have a few comments about some
of the policies give a few thoughts on
how I think about the economic growth
over the next ten years and in the long
run and also some comments about what
now so what lawmakers should focus on
going forward so general policy wise I
mean there were good accomplishments
here but by even no mean would I say
that this is an ideal tax reform package
the good stuff here are the things that
made improvements I think the lower
corporate tax rate is an improvement
it's going to reduce the incentive for
profit shifting it reduces the cost of
capital encourages additional investment
the new territorial tax system will for
the most part remove the incentive for
companies to shift their residents from
the United States over to other
countries the faster cost recovery the
hundred percent bonus expensing another
aspect that will increase investment
especially or only during the years in
which it is it applies I also think some
of the base broadening on the corporate
side was good especially limitations on
the interest expense deduction and then
on the individual side and I think alex
is going to get into this and much more
I think there was some good
simplifications especially with the
standard deduction that pushed a lot of
people into a much simpler world
of tax filing and I think there's also
some downsides to the tax law I think
the big one that I want to point out
more than anything is the temporary
nature of a large portion of the tax law
the individual portions of the tax law
are supposed to expire near the end of
the budget window 100 percent bonus is
going to expire in in four years and I
think that this was a consequence of
choosing to make the tax law a tax cut
rather than revenue neutral and I think
lawmakers they're betting on the ability
to be able to extend a lot of these
things they're hoping it's going to be
popular but I think from a tax payer
perspective that's a that's a risk and I
think it creates uncertainty for
taxpayers and sort of violates one of
these principles of good tax policy
which is stability I also think there
are some policy issues in the in the tax
law as well one of the big ones that I
want to point out is I don't think that
there's a significant justification for
the deduction for pass-through
businesses it's pretty complicated and I
think if you were to say that it is
something that we do need I think it
could have been structured a little
better and then there are some smaller
things about how the beat some
international provisions were structured
such as the beat and also the interest
deduction limitation especially in the
out-years I think there are some
incentive issues that that creates so
how do I think about the the economic
impact of of the tax law well I think
it's driven a lot by the lower cost of
capital especially in the first five
years with expensing this lower cost of
capital will drive additional investment
and in the long run I still think that
you'll have a lower cost of capital as
well especially do the corporate tax
rate is permanently lower here but I
think there are reasons why we should be
you know more realistic about how much
growth to expect not to think about this
as a permanent 3% increase in GDP growth
more like especially in the first years
a bigger boost but then in the long run
a more reasonable one
one is the temporary nature of expensing
to the expensing provision leaves out
buildings buildings is a large portion
of the capital stock in the United
States and instead of going for
expensing for all assets they just went
with 50% bonus and extended that law to
100% still leaving out a large section
of our capital sock then on the
individual side statutory rates were
reduced you would think that that's
going to increase labor force
participation encourage people to work a
little bit more but there's an
offsetting
effect especially those in upper middle
to upper income and that's the
elimination of the state and local tax
deduction and to be clear I I think
eliminating fully the state and local
tax deduction would be good policy but
it's also comes with a trade-off that it
does slightly boost marginal tax rates
for those that are paying there's state
and local income taxes and that is a
slight offsetting factor as well so from
the individual side I don't think you
should expect just a big a big change
there especially at the high end and one
reminder and this goes to the debate
about bonuses and buybacks and all that
a lot of these effects are long-run
effects and long-run effects on the size
of the economy and not the growth rate
don't expect investment in wages and all
that stuff to increase right after the
tax law was passed this stuff is going
to take time so directly pointing at you
know a certain bonus check that says
tcga on it is probably not you know the
smartest idea and this is a multi-year
thing where we need to waitin to see how
investment will play out in the long run
just to wrap this up what now for
lawmakers I think lawmakers should focus
on making as much of the good stuff in
the tax law as permanent as possible a
stable tax code is a better tax code
than in one that is unstable and then
related to that I think on the
individual side when thinking about what
to make permanent and what to allow to
expire
I think there should be a focus on
things that broaden the tax base and
make it simpler rather than focusing
significantly on lower statutory
individual income tax rates Thanks
thanks Kyle next we'll hear from a Miami
guiness from the committee for a
responsible federal budget thank you
thanks everybody and Alan and Alex thank
you very much for having us to AEI and I
like senator hatch I'm a big fan of the
scholarship that comes out of here also
every time I come to events here I
realize how much I love this conference
room but it wasn't until today I
realized how much I love those super
futuristic podiums so this is just great
AEI is a great organization for many
reasons I'm gonna touch upon just kind
of the pros and cons of the tax reform
as I see it and then dig a little bit
deeper into two of the bigger cons which
would be the fiscal effects and kind of
the unintended political economy
consequences that I think have come out
of it but to start with the good things
because there were a lot though I would
overall describe the tax reform slash
cut legislation as a big missed
opportunity but there are a lot of
reasons we definitely needed tax reform
I think that was widely widely believed
and a lot of those things were
accomplished in terms of lowering the
corporate tax rate quite significantly
which I think will help with
competitiveness and avoid a trend that I
really was worried about which was an
ongoing growth in corporate inversions
where corporations were leaving and the
changes to expensing so I think that
there were changes on the corporate side
that improved the the tax code in ways
that had been being discussed and as the
senator said did have bipartisan support
and were important to pursue a lot of my
goods are both in my good and bad quart
category but one of my goods also is
that there was some real progress on
base broadening so interest
deductibility was one of them on on the
corporate side I also think it was real
progress that we did something on a
state and local deduction and the home
mortgage interest deduction home
mortgage interest deduction many people
probably are big fans of it I have been
a big fan of eliminating or reforming it
and I experienced once that the only
death threat I ever got is what I wrote
an op-ed arguing that we should perform
the home mortgage interest deduction and
I unwisely placed it in the LA Times not
the place to run that op-ed but so I
know it's controversial but a lot of
these tax breaks that are in the tax
code and there are we're over one and a
half trillion of them per year are
actually part of the problem of tax
policy they are so inefficient and they
they pay people to do things they would
do anyhow they miss allocate resources
so I think making progress on some of
the reforms on ones that had been seen
as third rails was important not just
because of the policy but showing that
we can touch them that said there's a
lot of pushback and I'm really worried
at least on the state local that will
see some scaling back of their forms
instead of using that to start a further
discussion also as was mentioned I think
moving more people under the standard
deduction is very useful because it
moves you away from the whole world of
tax expenditures and using all of these
different tax breaks and which I would
rather have a diminished dependency on
so some of the weaknesses this Mike this
this isn't my bad column but I might
actually be good so the corporate rate
reduction was so much more aggressive
than most people thought it was going to
be I didn't think it needed to go as low
as it was going to I think that you
could have achieved a lot of the goals
with less of a cut in the corporate tax
rate and that would have been less
costly on the other hand I put myself in
the category of somebody who would
eliminate the corporate tax if we were
able to find a way to do it so
decreasing our dependency on the tax
overall is a good thing but we spent a
lot of money on lowering rates that if
we had paid for them I would have been a
big fan of given that they were deficit
financed I think we did more on rate
reduction than we had to certainly I
think the temporary nature of the tax
cuts is really problematic this just
exacerbates the problem that we have of
jumping from fiscal cliff to fiscal
cliff there was a huge irony throughout
all this which was lawmakers argued they
wanted to have their tax code code or
their tax cuts considered against a
current policy baseline which assumes
all expiring tax cuts are extended and
don't have to be paid for at the very
same time that they were saying Oh a lot
of our tax cuts will expire so we don't
have to pay for them
then kind of in a third inconsistent
point they would say but don't worry
wink wink we're going to extend them so
this just goes to budget baselines tax
baselines how we do this is really
problematic it's incredibly not
transparent and so if there's something
more complicated and perhaps less
interesting to most people than tax
policy will be budget process but there
is a budget process task force that's
going to go on this year and I think
looking at things like baselines and how
we mess around with them which can have
in this case it has a price tag of 500
billion dollars as part of the tax cut I
think that could be really important as
I mentioned there was a huge loss of not
doing much more base broadening the key
to making this tax reform right in my
mind would have been lowering the rates
as we did but also broadening the base
and we just did not tackle tax
expenditures nearly as much as we should
have there was very little discussion of
how we could eliminate most of them
simpson-bowles had an interesting idea
where you eliminate all of them and then
you decide on each tax break which one
is worth putting back in the tax code
and you increase your rates to offset
the cost of that it's really interesting
mechanism to put a cost on those tax
breaks which are incredibly costly but
appear to be free the way we have them
and I wish we'd tackled them a lot more
and had a much simpler base I do think
that we lost a huge opportunity by not
paying for this tax bill and I'll talk
about the fiscal effects but mainly
because the growth effects which are
really quite modest by almost all
accounts of this would have been higher
if they had not been deficit financed
tax cuts grow the economy debt decreases
growth in the economy and so it
undermines a lot of the potential growth
effects I think one of the most
important objectives that we can have
right now as a country is to find and
put in place a comprehensive economic
growth plan tax reform is a key part of
that it's a lost opportunity because we
didn't do it in enough of a pro-growth
way and debt not debt financing it would
have been very helpful to then on to the
fiscal effects we ended up with a tax
cut that will add one to two trillion
dollars to the national debt at a time
when the debt relative to the economy is
twice our historical average
twice where it was when we went into the
downturn of 2008 one of the biggest were
reasons to worry about deficits is
because when we hit a next downturn you
want to have both monetary policy and
fiscal policy available to help our
fiscal policy is hamstrung because we
have such high debt levels debt as a
share that company's the highest it's
been since right after World War Two
that makes no sense during a time of a
growing economy we should be bringing
that significantly down and we're on
course we were on course before this to
borrow another 10 trillion dollars where
debt would soon be reaching almost 100
percent of GDP
we're now on course to borrow after this
tax cut and a really irresponsible
spending increase anywhere from 12 or 11
to 14 trillion dollars and one of the
things I'm actually worried about is
that we're gonna start normalizing
trillions borrowing a trillion dollars
should not be okay we need to be finding
ways to save probably four three four
five trillion dollars over the next ten
years ideally if we wanted to get our
debt to a reasonable level and so this
is just we have a mammoth task in front
of us and by borrowing another trillion
to two trillion dollars depending if you
make this tax cut permanent or not we
have dug the hole like think of you're
looking at a mountain you're trying to
scale and it's already really difficult
to scale it and you're doing it as two
teams who are so busy beating each other
up like our two political parties are
that doing anything hard is even harder
and then you decide to dig a huge hole
and use that as your starting point
that's what we're doing every time we
borrow more instead of dealing with
these fiscal challenges so I don't want
to see borrowing so much for our tax cut
and then a subsequent spending bill
normalizing don't worry we can borrow
for everything but I think that's one of
the big negative x so to move on to my
too political economy effects I think
normalizing borrowing is a huge problem
I think we broke kind of the fiscal
constraints that existed given how high
our debt is we should be really worried
about it but suddenly we're in this
mentality of don't worry it will pay for
itself
everything will pay for itself and kind
of free lunch economics another thing I
worried about in the whole tax debate
was the loss of trust in numbers and
it's sort of two things on one hand on
this panel there are a lot of people who
put out
their own numbers including our
organization that were really ours where
everybody's that yours or yours were
really useful in the debate it was
really great to kind of see the free
flowing of new information enhancing and
improving the information that's out
there and also gonna just give a
shout-out to Kyle I also learned what
really good tweeting is through some of
the work of him and his colleagues but
there are really good discussions that
you could have about deep tax policy
that very useful but at the same time
what we also saw was politicians
basically just making up numbers that
were not in the realm of possibilities
that's really damaging when you're kind
of arguing for growth effects that
aren't likely to happen in any of the
normal models and I want to make sure
that we continue to use good empirical
analysis to help guide our policymaking
and the final concern I have is that big
tax cuts that weren't paid for undermine
the arguments for what we really need to
do to get our fiscal situation under
control which is reforms of our big
mandatory programs Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid and because we
have such a politically polarized
environment and we had one no Democrats
participated in the tax cut vote so we
had one partisan tax bill that has now
got an excuse to the other party to say
we're not showing up in helping on
entitlement reform at all and frankly a
very few Republicans pushing for it at
the moment - we have set the set taken
many many steps back and what we need to
be doing to tackle the fiscal challenges
so I'm really worried about the overall
political economy effects as well as the
fiscal effects and I would just end
saying it was such an important
opportunity to do tax reform right and
basically because we weren't willing to
do the hard work of offsetting the costs
which I would have said was from
broadening the base I think we lost a
tremendous amount in that opportunity
thanks Maya
now we'll hear again from Alex Brill
Thank You Ellen
and thanks everyone for for being here
it was nice to see that not very many
people left when senator hatch left so a
serious tax crowd here
I want to there's so many parts of this
PACs bill there's a tendency I think to
focus
a lot on the macro impacts and those are
important those are a driving force and
motivation behind this reform but there
are so many many other smaller impacts
that we're going to really discover over
the next few years that we can begin to
identify as potential policy changes and
I want to just touch on a couple of them
in a minute but we focus a lot on them
on what the level of GDP might be a
decade from now
and sometimes appreciate the fact that
the composition of GDP may also be
changing both industry to industry or or
other factors as well we could see I
think likely changes in how firms
finance their investment so there's a
question about what the levels of
investment are gonna be it's been widely
discussed but also I think we should
expect changes and things like the use
of debt versus the use of of equity
going forward as as Maya noted in
addition to the economic changes of this
bill I'm there gonna be a lot of there
are a lot of political economy aspects
that are important as well the question
to Senator hatch earlier I think is a
really valuable one what that what will
be the response of other governments on
well with the response of our own
government in future congresses and what
will be the response of state local
governments to the changes that were
enacted and what will be the change the
responses to foreign governments and so
there's just I feel sometimes almost
overwhelmed with the the myriad of
changes and the sort of questions that
it poses when we when we sort of start
to drill down on under the more micro
level of the bill of this magnitude I
want to just take a couple minutes and
try to get us a little bit back on track
time wise and and talk about some
changes on the individual side Kyle
mentioned them senator hatch actually
talked about it more than I would have
anticipated and that changes due to and
related to the change in the standard
deduction you know increasing the
standard deduction was never really a
traditional Republican objective and tax
reform it was always about bringing down
statutory rates but for a number of
years as this tax reform has has a
matured and evolved and ultimately
became law Republicans have
and advocating for a large increase in
the standard deduction and so I just
want to touch on on three consequences
of that or three things that have been
suggested one is the increase in the
standard deduction as a matter of
simplification and fairness using AE
eyes on modeling something called the
ospc the open source policy centers
which is a platform here at AI for doing
tax analysis using the ospc model we
looked at the the pre-imposed impact of
tax reform and particularly the changes
as a result relates to the standard
deduction absent tax reform that would
have been forty five point two million
tax filers who itemized in 2018 as a
result of tax reform nineteen point four
million will will itemize an increase in
standard deduction takers of about
twenty six million this is a dramatic
simplification of course earlier
versions of the tax reform bill would
have gone further putting even more
people on the standard deduction but but
fewer than half as many as previous and
so who cares what's that what's the
impact well the senator hatch said
obviously this makes the forms I'm easy
er to fill out assuming we're not doing
this on a computer or having someone do
it for us but it also promotes a
fairness in an important degree a type
of fairness I don't think we talked
about enough horizontal equity to
taxpayers in the same situation do they
pay the same amount of tax and so in my
view to taxpayers who are identical
except one rent in one owns in my view
those two taxpayers should pay the same
amount of tax as a result of this change
that will be more true not completely
true but but closer to truth so there'll
be more taxpayers who are in similar
situations starting from the same
starting point both taking the standard
deduction and that promotes an important
type of fairness in the system and I
think it has actually political economy
implications because I think it improves
the trust in the system if people sort
of have a sense that their neighbor or
their co-worker
whose similarly-situated is probably
paying about the same amount of tax I
think they probably have a lot more
trust in the system I think in the old
system they thought that was probably
unlikely that there in fact that their
neighbor or their co-worker was probably
paying less and in many cases that was
true I think that's an important part of
the tax reform there are other
consequences of the increase in the
standard deduction and that I want to
just touch on briefly one is the impact
on charitable giving so under the old
system where large numbers of people
were itemized errs thirty five point
seven million filers claimed some amount
of charitable giving on their tax return
and received a deduction for that
received a federal subsidy for that
giving under the new law sixteen point
four million only sixteen point four
thirty thirty almost thirty six ten to
sixteen so a decline of about twenty
million returns that claimed charitable
giving now for these tax payers who are
affected this way
the price of giving rises to $1 for for
every dollar of it they give previously
it was one minus their tax rate so it
could have been as low as sixty five
cents
cost to them to give a dollar away now I
think that this policy is as it was
previously structured in fact as its
structured today is sort of it's pretty
strange for one reason we have a
charitable giving subsidy that's
primarily available for those
individuals who are homeowners and live
in high tax states in other words it's a
subsidy for those who are who are
itemize errs and not since not everyone
is an itemized er we're encouraging some
but not others and of course among the
group of taxpayers that were subsidizing
we're tossing them at different rates
because they face different tax rates
now I'm working on an estimate of what
the impact and I'm doing that with my
colleague here at AEI Derek joy she and
I are trying to to put a number price
tag on what that impact will be on
charitable giving our preliminary
finding is that the from a static sense
meaning holding constant the size the
economy charitable giving will probably
drop by about twelve billion dollars as
a read of the result of this tax bill
that sounds like a lot of money it's not
inconsequential it's relative to about
four hundred billion dollars in
will giving and I do think however that
that the growth effects of the overall
package will be important to consider in
this project as well and to the extent
that the economy is growing and people
have more incomes than the actual
dynamic number will be will be less let
me touch on one more issue and then I'll
I'll stop talking which is the potential
impact of tax reform on unoccupied
housing the National Association of real
threats the the National Association of
Realtors called the house tax bill quote
an outright assault on home ownership in
America and a study they commissioned
warned that comprehensive tax reform
House Republican style would result in
an average drop in home values of 10
percent and so a valiant effort and
tense lobbying campaign by them included
these these campaign slogans furthermore
the number of people who are able to
utilize the home workers introduction
Falls from about 36 million down to
about sixteen point seven million and so
that sort of further feeds this story
that housing is gonna take it on the
chin um
I think that that's false and I would
remind folks particularly folks who live
in this area that the median home price
in America is two hundred thirteen
thousand dollars a little bit hard for
us to imagine in this neighborhood in
these neighborhoods but lots of
taxpayers even under the old system
aren't using this policy in many
neighborhoods and maybe many communities
many are unaffected the changes in
addition we should remember the the
provision still exists and so of course
people who are no longer utilizing it
are oftentimes not always oftentimes
choosing not to use all I said because
they're receiving a larger tax break
from the new system so there's more cash
in hand
let me just wrap up by saying there's
some academic literature on this front
as well and this month's American
Economic Review Camilla summer and Paul
solving try to estimate the impact of
outright repeal they find the impact
would be only four percent which i think
is also even an underestimate so let me
wrap up there and stop and
and and turn it back daddy thanks Alex
and last but not least we'll hear from
Marty Sullivan of tax analysts Thank You
Alan thank you Alex
thank thank you all for being here good
morning I have some slides it's great to
be on this prestigious panel but they
didn't leave me anything to talk about
so I'll try to squeeze something in the
astute people in the audience will
notice an error on this slide but we'll
just leave right over that that's the
best it's going to get folks pros and
cons of the bill what I want to focus on
just to give it a little is to focus on
the business side and look I just want
to ask the question our business is more
likely to locate their factories in the
United States before or after the bill
so let's go through the major pros and
cons of what's in this bill
so as obviously the major benefit is the
14% rate cut and when you factor in the
state and local deduction and a loss of
section 199 which was sort of like a
rate cut it's really only 12 and a half
percent cut but twelve and a half
percent is a huge change expensing only
for five years and only for equipment
assets less than 20 years but it is a
major benefit so we got those two things
going on that's gonna help incentivize
investment in the United States on the
minus side you have interest limitations
which if you are financing through debt
are going to be a negative but the
magnitude of that seems to be relatively
small but it is there we have something
we in the tax world called fitty FDI I
there's a lot of debate about what the
how we should say it we'll leave that
that's the biggest debate in economics
right now but what it is it is a
thirteen point two five percent rate for
in certainly income generated in the
United States related to exports so
that's an additional incentive
to invest in the United States then we
have something else called guilty which
was originally set up to prevent foreign
firms from getting unfair tax advantages
visa vie US firms it didn't come out
that way in the end basically it is it
does to reduce tax benefits for
investing in the United States so that's
going to see it's going to guilty that's
going to help investment in the United
States the hurt investment the United
States and then we also have what's
called the beat and what the beat does
is it increases taxes of US firms
operating abroad so where before you
might have been able with some deft
tracked tax planning to pay 0% of
borrowed this is like a minimum tax that
hits you with a 30 with up to a thirteen
point two five percent rate and there
are a lot of details that actually might
be higher and then finally there's a
whole bunch of other stuff in the bill
that people don't talk about because
this is more than enough but in general
they raise business taxes now I built
because I'm an economist they built the
model I put this all together I made a
whole bunch of assumptions and when I
added them all up on average and there
are no average firms in the United
States so with that caveat it is a net
this bill is a net positive for American
business it's a net positive for foreign
firms to invest in the United States a
net positive for American firms to stay
in the United States however the playing
field is still tilted a little bit in
favor of foreign investment so it's I'm
not trying to be cute here I'm just
trying to is that the tilt of the
playing field is more in favor of the
United States but it's still a little
bit negative this is a very preliminary
assessment so I reserve the right to
change my mind now what I just talked
about were the direct effects of the
legislation there's a lot of other stuff
going on besides what's in the statute
and I always want to mention that rise
deficits which of course Maya is focused
on by Lola Maya has one of the greatest
quotes if I can get it from memory if I
please correct me the the grown-ups in
Congress after the yeah spending bill
where they did 300 billion in two years
the grown-ups in Congress are having a
feast and they passed the bill on to the
kids table I think that's that really
does summarize what what's Congress did
but any rate the economic effects of
deficits are not good they're gonna
raise interest rates in to cause
crowding out so we have to consider that
effect as well we have to consider the
reaction function economists call it of
what foreign governments are going to do
and if foreign governments cut their
taxes in response to our tax cut well
that's not therefore that's tilting the
playing field back to the foreign side
so if we reduce art you know to take the
extreme example if we reduce ours by
12.5% and everybody else reduces theirs
by 12.5% well then you know nothing
ain't and almost every time I talk to
somebody from another country yesterday
it was Australia but you have India
China possibly Germany France UK they're
all talking they're all doing or very
seriously talking about cutting their
rates so this is going to dilute the
benefits of tax reform for us state
governments are talking about increasing
their taxes as they go hey you just got
a 12 and a health 12 a 14 percent tax
cut you're a you're a sitting duck for a
tax increase
so that would diminish the benefits of
this and then finally there's
uncertainty uncertainty and uncertainty
there and uncertainty is very bad for
investment we have built it we didn't
deal with the extenders in this bill in
fact we added new extenders to this bill
so that's built-in uncertainty into the
law we have because we have larger
deficits I'm an old enough to remember
the 1981 tax cuts of Ronald Reagan and
immediately after that the deficit
exploded and we had to have 82 tax
increases in 84 tax increases that is
not out of the question that this will
happen again so considering investing in
the United States long term as it really
gonna is this tax cut really going to be
permanent and then the other thing which
is dominating the practicioner can
which is only about 900,000 people in
the United States nobody really
understands what's going on in this bill
practitioners who have been studying
this since December 22nd when it was
signed into law are still trying to
figure out what to tell their clients
their clients don't know what they
should do for with respect to tax
planning what they should do with
respect to their in long term investment
ideas so this is a major problem and
that's a result of how fast the bill
largely a result of how fast the bill
went through Congress foreign
governments are talking about treaty
violations and WTO violations which
might negate some of this and then I
there is a chance that Republicans might
not stay in power for the next seven
years and because this was such a
partisan bill it is politically unstable
so all of these factors are working sort
of subtly behind the scenes I have one
more minute because it's very strict and
I'll just show you one last slide which
is a very simple slide the blue line is
projected deficits from the CBO the
latest available numbers are from August
so these are ancient but that's all we
got that's the blue line and as you can
see Ann is Maya stressed we are gonna be
borrowing a lot even before this tax
bill we're gonna be borrowing a lot of
money then I myself added on top of this
the effect of the tax cuts which of
course increases the deficit so you see
we're going to be at about a trillion
dollars before you know in 2020 now this
was before this is before the 300
billion dollar over two-year spending
bill so that red line is gonna go up
even more so we are in absolutely
unprecedented territory because even if
you go back to 1946 we knew the deficit
was gonna go down there if this line was
extended out it would be up over here
and the one reason we can be certain
about that we economists are very bad at
predicting things but the MOG refers are
very good at predicting
population and our population is aging
so what you need to look for
coming soon any game now and I've been
waiting every day is the CBO is going to
bring out their new economic and budget
outlook and then we're gonna have new
official Rockettes
or as solid as these things get
nonpartisan deficit numbers and the
story in Washington is going to be the
deficit and Maya's gonna have tons of
work to do thank you great thanks Marty
well thanks to all of the panelists all
of you did stay within the strict
10-minute limit and you cover an amazing
amount of ground in discussing this very
wide-ranging law so luckily we do have
some time for audience questions please
wait to be called upon and also wait for
the microphone to come to you and then
if you could introduce yourself and your
organization bob gould ER with tax how
bad does the debt need to get before the
border adjustment is back on the table i
you know those are words we thought we
would never hear again water adjustment
okay yeah i don't know i I think that
most economists believe that the
long-run solution to the country's
fiscal imbalance will end up being a
value-added tax now the interesting
thing about a value-added tax is of
course that it is border adjustment and
border adjusting it is not controversial
for various reasons that we don't have
time to go into all these issues that
came up in the debate in 2017 about
border adjustment gets sidestepped when
there's a bad we don't have a WTO
problem people don't worry about
exchange rates etc etc etc so I guess
you could argue in that sense the border
adjustment would eventually show up I
think in a value-added tax now when I
say that we're likely to have with
value-added tax I don't mean this year I
don't mean next year I don't necessarily
mean this decade but I mean that as we
head into the upcoming decades you know
that's the
have I and I think that will end up on
certainly the path that almost every
other country in the world has taken I
just had and the the question is such a
good one given the fact that the cost of
the bill was the cost of the revenue you
know the trillion half dollar net impact
of the bill is exactly what would have
the whole that would have been filled
with a border adjustment tax and that's
also happens to be the cost of the
corporate tax cut so these this 1.5
trillion dollar number is somehow magic
not necessarily in a good way
and it's at some point we're gonna need
to find a solution yeah great question I
I don't know what the tipping point for
people waking up about the debt is going
to because it should have already
happened I do think that I do think when
CBO comes out with this numbers and
actually we're gonna come out with a
bunch of updated numbers this week on
what the deficit estimates are going to
be so there's a little teaser the
numbers won't be good but I think
there's the chance that the trillion
dollar number gets a lot more attention
in the media the last time we had
trillion-dollar deficits it's when we
had a huge huge recession 2008 and that
was a wake up call about fiscal issues
even though fiscal issues weren't the
primary problem at the moment the
recession was so this time I think
unless unless we have become just kind
of so used to it that we don't care I
think we're about to have a pretty big
wake-up call and I'm curious what 2020
is going to look like when this this is
an issue fiscal issues and making the
hard choices to fix the problem that
doesn't come from the grassroots it
comes from the top-down and so I think
the presidential election and whether
the discussion looks at it will make a
huge difference so the question of what
will make us start to care enough that
we take some actions I don't know I
guess the best I'm doing right now is
sort of standing ready from whenever
there's an opening with a lot of ideas
to move forward but I do like alum
saying I think the border adjustment tax
will come back in a different form and
or a carbon tax is likely to be on the
table and basically that my conclusion
is if we hadn't done this tax cut we
would probably be still thinking about
base broadening in ways to get new
revenue from tax reform but now that we
did I think a new revenue stream maybe
five years from now is much more likely
than it was before and let me just say
in 1992 when the death death GDP ratio
was about third
five percent two candidates one named
Bill Clinton and another one a crazy guy
named Ross Perot who ended up getting
90% of the vote ran on reducing the
deficit and we don't have any of that I
mean look at this this presidential last
presidential campaign seventeen
Republicans ran none of them were
talking about reducing the deficit and I
don't think mrs. Clinton was either so
we really need Ross Perot Pats fan I
just retired gubby I wonder if you guys
could look in the crystal ball and
because I I noticed I ran in numbers
with the rates if you had a taxable
income over 165 K you saved 5,000 about
five thousand a year in taxes but the
reduction of the personal exemption and
miscellaneous deductions and the limit
on the state tax pretty well eliminates
that may be a wash for a lot of people
so I'm wondering if you look in your
crystal ball and what do you think that
the likelihood that when people finally
realize that the personal exemption is
gone and things like home equity
interest is gone and the miscellaneous
deductions especially asset management
fees are gone how likely are they to
stay in in the law I can take this so I
think that the the group of people that
are sort of on that margin where the
elimination of the personal exemption
plus the higher standard deduction and
some limitations on I my deductions are
right around where you speak where
you're talking like upper upper middle
class taxpayers where it's like okay
maybe I'll get like a $40 tax cut or
I'll get a slight tax increase you know
I don't know whether that's enough
pressure to say oh okay we got to scrap
this I mean that's not a majority of
people most people are down at a much
lower levels of income where they're
getting the benefit of the standard
deduction significantly along with the
larger child
it's credit there is another issue that
lurking in your question I think which
beyond the fact that some people may
find themselves with tax increases as if
certainly a minority of taxpayers will
but there is also just policy provisions
in this law that I think have not gotten
a lot of attention and you mentioned the
elimination of the miscellaneous
itemized deductions so employee business
expense to duction is in that category
and so that's been eliminated that's a
broad category and I think there's some
expenses being claimed there they do
have a very large personal component to
them nevertheless some of those really
are costs of earning income and the
decision to repeal that deduction I
think really has a lot of implications
and as far as I can tell that received
almost no attention during the
deliberations over the bill and still is
received very little attention even
though the bill was signed into law two
months ago the moving expense deduction
was also eliminated that was intended
you know to provide tax relief for
people who are moving to take a new job
I think some of the same issues there
I think there's pro and con arguments
you can make on these provisions but
there really are some things lurking in
there people don't fully realize they're
in there yet I to wonder how policy will
evolve once those provisions become more
widely known
thank you distinguished panel Andrew I'm
from congressman Paulson's office and my
question is specifically for miss
McGinnis but anyone else who can answer
for free to share expertise you've
written before very eloquently miss
McGinnis in the written forum that
entitlement reform is one of your
possible solutions to pay for this huge
reform of taxes can you go a little bit
into in a perfect world if there was the
political leverage for that what those
intent reforms would look like do you
have specific policy ideas or best
practices that if this does become
possible which programs we should look
at and what types of reforms we should
be aware of most sure happily but let me
just reframe that that I don't I didn't
write that entitlement reform should be
put in place to pay for the tax cut
because I think that's what kills
entitlement reform we had to do
entitlement reform before the tax cut
both because it's the part of our budget
that's growing so fast
squeezing out all other parts of the
budget and putting fiscal pressure on
and because if we don't make changes to
Social Security and Medicare there are
going to be really potentially
devastating cuts particularly in Social
Security where there'll be abrupt cuts
across the board if we wait until the
trust funds aren't able to pay for full
benefits so we need to fix entitlements
and I'll say how but I think having done
the tax cuts first in the form of cuts
that weren't revenue neutral either
through base broadening or spending cuts
that were attached at the time we've
made this much more difficult because
the framing is now like she want to take
money out of Social Security to pay for
those tax cuts for corporations and that
is a terrible frame that does a real
disservice to getting it done so we
still need to do it as much as ever and
I would argue we're going to need new
revenue to deal with the fiscal
challenges that we have unquestionably I
thought we needed to before that we
could have gotten out of tax reform I
think after the tax cuts we need it more
than ever
but the key issues are we are living
longer if you take Social Security when
it was built when it was created the
retirement age was 65 the life
expectancy was 62 that was a program
that was going to make sense and work
actually until of course the first
recipient a Tammy Fuller lived to be a
hundred which should have been like a
little teaser of what was going to
happen but I think you have to look at
how you slow the growth of benefits in
those programs for people who don't
depend on the program more so I
definitely think slowing the growth at
the top end makes sense I think you have
to calculate CPI using something called
chained CPI which is a more accurate
measure and I certainly think we have to
look at how to gradually increase the
retirement age and index that to
longevity Ida index as many things as
possible because Congress doesn't like
to make hard choices so if you can build
those indexes into the program they
happen automatically that would be a lot
easier I think you're also going to need
new revenue to put into those programs
but what I urge is before we think about
putting more money into a program like
Social Security or Medicare let's look
at all the needs in the budget when I
think about looking forward what we need
this economy is changing so dramatically
in terms of global as the effects from
globalization technology
gee the future of work and I would much
rather think about new resources after
we deal with the fiscal situation that
we decide we want to spend going into
things like lifelong education and
worker retraining keeping us competitive
as a workforce figuring out what the
future of work looks like in a changing
economy
so rather than increasing or paying for
all of my retirement benefits assuming I
won't need all of them
I would rather have those resources go
somewhere else and then finally there's
still so much to be done in healthcare
the controlling cost portion of
healthcare hasn't got enough of the
attention we don't know how to fix that
I can tick off all the things I'm Social
Security pretty easily it's just a bunch
of levers you move healthcare we have to
keep trying to control costs in as many
ways as possible I think changing
incentives is a critical piece of that
and continue to expand those throughout
the system but there are others on the
panel who also know a lot about the
topics okay all right well unfortunately
our time has come to an end please join
me in thanking our distinguished panel
[Applause]
[Music]